que va faire philippe couillard à cuba
il quitte lundi soir vient mercredi
ce n'est pas pour se faire dorer la
couenne au soleil l'émission est
économique renforcer les liens
d'affaires alors que l'assouplissement
de l'embargo américain sur l'île de
castro représente une nouvelle
concurrence mais aussi une ouverture du
marché cubain
vous vous demandez qu'est ce que les
québécois font à cuba rapport se mettre
les deux piles en sable en fait c'est
beaucoup moins exotique et fils de
cuivre représenter en 2015 plus de vrais
% des 84 millions de dollars de
marchandises exportées à cuba suivi de
la viande de porc fraîche des partis
pour charrier automobile des morceaux de
coq et de poules et des parties de
moteurs diesel
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
depuis 2011 les exportations ont bondi
de 28% et on importe pas mal moins plus
deux millions et demi de dollars du café
torréfié principalement bon cubant
représente une part non négligeable des
échanges commerciaux call québec avec
l'amérique latine soit 0 8%
n'empêche le gouvernement espère établir
de nouveaux partenariats notamment en
matière d'éducation de santé de
coopératisme le tourisme et
d'agriculture pour sa visite à cuba fils
couillard sera accompagné d'entreprises
et d'institutions québécoise